I've been coming here to San Francisco
since about 1996 or so and
this has always been one of my favorite
American cities forget politics I love
its architecture it's a landscape the
rich history of this place
but what I've seen happening to San
Francisco especially just over the last
few years
I mean it's nothing short of
heartbreaking
how long would it take me to get cracked
under a minute how about heroin same
thing fentanyl same
easy to get very easy to get less than
two years ago I was right here in the
tenderloin District here in San
Francisco it's an open-air drug Market
we decided to come back to see whether
things have improved or gotten worse
within the past week uh the tenderloin
had three shootings uh one resulted in a
homicide one resulted in another person
being shot and another resulted in a car
being shot up
just in this District yeah just in this
District Lieutenant Tracy McRae has been
with the San Francisco police department
for nearly 30 years after spending 11 in
the Army this is Ground Zero here in the
tenderloin district for hardcore drug
addicts in the area correct right I mean
you just take a look around and you see
people addicted to fentanyl crystal meth
you know heroin you got your crack
cocaine still but you got your garden
variety of all the type of drugs and
this is where you're going to find
people who are on all of these different
drugs just walking around we're gonna go
down the street and you're going to see
someone who's shooting up right right in
broad daylight while it's tempting to
turn your heads away from the human
sadness and suffering on these streets I
decided to speak firsthand with those in
the grips of addiction how old are you
38 years
eight years family I have a husband and
I have children
you got to get clean man
yeah I gotta get clean I have to get
clean
um
but um since I've been on the street
um because that's the one I just barely
started using fentanyl
where are you getting the fentanyl from
up the street from people but to me
fentanyl has been uh like
like something that's helping keeping me
alive it helps me not think about some
of the trauma that I've been through
when I don't get it like
I like can't breathe sometime or have
anxiety really bad
but when I have it like I immediately
calm down
I immediately calmed down
um okay
the human need is great after seeing
this firsthand it's going to take a lot
more police and a lot more creative
thinking to get this situation cleaned
up how many police officers in the city
currently right now 580.
what would a fully staffed police force
be able to do about you know about this
poor guy I mean a fully staffed police
force uh could be out here connecting
with people trying to get them connected
to services but we need those Partners
out here too yeah right so that's that's
the thing they all say we get all this
money this billion dollar organization
we get all this money but where do you
see the boots on the ground from the
community organizations out here trying
to help that man trying to help that man
across the street trying to help that
lady in the doorway trying to help that
man rot in a blanket where are they
see that that's my problem they have to
worry about that history so your point
is off the streets your choices jail or
treatment that's it that's it those are
the only two choices you get and right
now what happens
you get none of that you get to stay out
here and do you can just live out here
do as much drugs as you want because
uh the injunction about clearing tents
and homeless Camp campus so you can't
clear it out you can't do that no right
that's what they want us to do they want
us to but we can't do it by law right a
judge says no unless you can provide a
bed for every person you see out here
and my whole thing is when did that fall
on us that's that's not my issue
right like I give I am My Brother's
Keeper but damn how much keeping does
one person have to do for another adult
who makes these choices that's the other
thing here nobody ever talks about these
are adults
who are making choices to be out here to
do this Lieutenant McRae knows all too
well the dangers of having a department
stretch too thin as an officer and even
herself at one time as a victim of crime
the police are not the solution we can't
be the only solution and until people
want to make these hard decisions and
tell people no then this will continue
to happen
you will see this and you'll come back
in two years and it'll be much worse in
2020 mayor London breed caught 120
million dollars from police and Sheriff
departments in the city directing it to
address disparities in the black
community three years later she wants to
give more money and even call the
National Garden to deal with the drug
issue no it actually means it's a
division of their unit their
intelligence unit helping you know
gather information to try and stem the
flow of where these drugs are
identifying you know but it's not boots
on the ground there's no tank rolling
through this intersection or anywhere in
the tenderloin right that's not what it
is it's the CHP coming and helping maybe
doing traffic stops because maybe if
they do a traffic stop they might find
someone who does have drugs and stop
that
from bring coming into the community but
it doesn't mean by any stretch of the
imagination that you will see green
fatigues marching up and down will it
help
clean this up at all is this gonna be
cleaned up when you have no
no no
do you have hope for this city
I mean I have hope but it's going to be
a a long-term kind of Hope project so
we're talking maybe five years 10 years
down the road to recover right San
Francisco bounced back it always has but
this one is going to be a little bit
tougher to bounce back from
a heartbreaking uh
I'm going to be thinking about a lot of
those individuals I saw on the streets
today and but for the grace of God go
any of us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else